do you write the majority of parks and
recreation no we have a cast of a staff
of writers and I write an episode a year
right
um uh but and I I get to direct you know
episode as well but no we have a great
staff of writers but the show was your
idea right no Michael sure Mike sure
who's a producer and a Creator from a
weekend update at SNL he started working
on the office the um American version of
the office and then he went off with
Greg Daniels and started Parks and Rec
were you scared when you started Parks
and Recreation because you never carried
a show and also everyone looks at you
after Saturday Night Live Like if that
tanks then your career is over and all
that like with all that pressure getting
to you
you know
I think I knew working with Mike it
would be really fun and funny I did we
did kind of get hammered in the
beginning of that show because we were
comparing to the office yeah yeah and
Steve Carell who's a genius and this is
going to be the seventh and last season
how are we feeling about the last season
super sad great job I love the people
everybody on the show are such huge fans
of yours but um why is it the last
season because we've done 125 right and
everybody's contracts are up right and
and you know we've had this like great
run but not huge ratings right so we're
always kind of on the bubble every year
and we wanted to kind of get ahead of we
wanted to be in control of the ending
which is so rare in Television right
because you're you're saying hey if
we're not he says huge rating success
they could cancel at any season and you
never have finale yeah in the finale
that last show and have you read the
finale have they actually no that's
happening next week Mike sure and I are
writing the finale together because
finales are especially in comedies are
always disappointing you don't know why
are they disappointing because we
haven't written it yet so what do you
think is disappointing about it I think
it's that people's expectations are just
too high and then sometimes they make
the mistake and I think that you'll be
smarter than this sometimes they make
the mistake that they feel there has to
be some fantastic moment so they go
completely out of character they go
completely against what they've done all
along and my thing too is that the
characters end up doing scenes with
people they've never done scenes with
right so all you want to see is the six
people that you like in a room